il
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé à jouer aux jeux
vidéo
c'est une passion
[Musique]
tu dois essayer des semaines
les saillies d'être la personne dans mon
jour
la force d'y jouer l'esprit de
compétition embarqué au point de mire
mal sec
la terre du contrôle c'est clair qu'on
avait un problème
c'était vraiment une centaine d'heures
nécessaires
francis 18 ans et ses parents et l'aîné
sébastien nous racontent leur combat
face à mener ni qui semblait pourtant
inoffensif dans cette famille de delson
en banlieue de montréal
il ya toujours eu des règles et des
limites quant au temps consacré aux jeux
vidéo
on était des parents encadrant canton se
comparer à nos amis qui avaient des
enfants à peu près du même âge on voyait
très bien que les limites si on mettait
beaucoup plus sévère que ça faisait
partie
francis n'a que 13 ans quand il découvre
league of legends un jeu de bataille en
ligne multijoueurs malgré les limites
le jeu prend progressivement une place
excessive dans la vie de francis qui est
atteint de troubles anxieux et d'un
trouble du déficit de l'attention
un td a avec le trouble d'anxiété qui
entrent en jeu moi c'était vraiment une
façon justement de m'évader sortir du
monde réel me concentrer le mot sur
autre chose
de nombreuses études démontrent que les
personnes ayant des troubles mentaux
tels que la dépression l'anxiété ou même
le td a avec ou sans hyperactivité sont
plus à risque de développer une
dépendance
on parle de jeunes qui ont des choix
plus introverti la timidité des jeunes
qui ont été vécues l'inspiration et
jeunes qui sont à la recherche aussi des
sensations fortes
[Musique]
est prêt à tout pour jouer la situation
est de plus en plus complexes agirait
pour ses parents quand est-ce que ça
devient un problème quand est ce que ça
ne l'est pas belle la ligne 'stable' les
besoins fondamentaux sont peu respectés
et est en période de croissance
fortement
c'est comme de base faut peut-être la
vie il faut que tu dormes la nuit ça
c'est la base etc ce cas le jeu vidéo et
nuire à ce sérieux problème c'est
quelque chose que je suis pas fier que
d'admettre main j'ai menti j'ai volé
j'ai triché g n'y a pas grand-chose qui
ont aujourd'hui moins confuse et c'est
que j'étais un monstre dans les
dernières années c'est quand ton fils de
main continue allemandes
quand ils volent cantini ce crime c'est
pas mon gars c'est pas dans mes valeurs
choisirait pas d'avoir une relation avec
quelqu'un à l'extérieur mais le c'est
mon fils qu'il faut que je fasse quelque
chose construit
il est si difficile de contrôler francis
surtout la nuit que l'achat de coffre
fort pour ranger les manettes fils et
ipod semble être la solution
mais la volonté de jouer de francis à
l'époque n'avait pas de limites même le
coffre-fort n'a pas résisté c'est moi
qui le briser j'ai trouvé le moyen avec
beaucoup d'efforts de volonté de
n'ouvrir pour donner une des quel point
l'époque c'était quelque chose de
primordial
les résultats scolaires de francis sont
en chute libre
le croyons commencent à jouer la nuit
qui dormait pas on le voyait dans ses
résultats parce que les files coulisses
par sa seconde à 3
[Musique]
au fil des ans bien des chercheurs ont
souligné les risques de dépendances
associé aux jeux vidéo ou réseaux
sociaux et à l'utilisation générale
d'internet
or la cyber dépendance n'est toujours
pas un diagnostic reconnue médicalement
pour la classe dans la catégorie des
troubles qui requièrent plus de
recherche
il faut donc utiliser le terme cyber
dépendance avec prudence malgré tout de
plus en plus de personnes se disent
divers dépendantes et réclame de l'aide
et des appels de parents qui est
extrêmement inquiet découragée qui cogné
à plusieurs portes qui arrivait pas
avoir de service comme tel dans sa
touchette un rendement scolaire les
conflits à la maison les communications
des fois de l'isen à court de solutions
hélène cherche du soutien
elle découvre le centre de réadaptation
en dépendance de longueuil qui depuis
2008 offre gratuitement de
l'intervention familiales notamment à
des accros de jeux vidéo comme francis
une thérapie pour le jeu vidéo ben
voyons dans c'est quoi ça au début je me
disais qu'ils étaient probablement fou
il a 14 ans lors de sa première visite
au centre c'est surtout moi comptes aux
français ses parents reviennent au
centre rencontrer leur intervenante
ghislaine et doris pour constater tout
le cheminement parcouru alors que moi
jamais je trouve une place et cherré ici
je serai deux autres comme ça et
peut-être le tas s'il le faut pas perdre
le contact pour pour qu'il soit doan hop
qui sort ces écouteurs avec qui nous
écoutent plus bars le même si on n'aime
pas ce qu'on attend pour les parents
c'est un problème de jeu c'est tout le
jeu qui nécessairement responsable de
tous les maux c'est pas nécessairement
ce que j'entends des adolescents qui
font dire c'est pas le jeu qui le
problème c'est beaucoup d'autres choses
vivantes nomine sculpté soit l'école
discuter dans la famille si ce boulot
qu'on donne un sens aussi
16 centre de réadaptation offre d
intervention du genre au québec soit un
par région ce sont surtout des garçons
qui recourent dans une proportion de 88
%
si vous aviez à décrire ce que vous avez
vécu ici à des gens qui connaissent pas
du tout la réadaptation beaucoup de
dédramatisation c'est ce qui me permet
de sortir de nos émotions opi de
négocier parce qu'on a vu que c'est
souvent j'ai demandé à francis s'il
était plus heureux dans le monde réel ou
virtuel je voulais rien savoir du monde
rires ça fait quelque chose qui me
plaisent et ce sans manche aller à
l'école parce qu'il fallait que j'aille
à l'école c'est quand je parle avec mes
amis ça me change les idées que je
faisais pour moi c'est devenu pénible
c'était devenu vers un fardeau mais j'ai
juste hâte que je peut se retourner chez
nous pour aller prendre la manette et il
n'est pas le seul dans une étude
québécoise 54 % des participants
indiquent que leur vie virtuelle est
plus satisfaisante que leur vie réelle
incapable de vaincre son envie de jouer
francis fait plusieurs rechutes
il fait même semblant d'aller au cégep
pour retourner dans la poutre son avatar
enfin parce que je fais au final dans le
jeu reste un hic c'est que c'est aussi
pour moi ça veut un impact alors qu'au
final je me disais dans vie réelle je
n'ai pas l'impression de l'être image
est toujours une crainte et dans ma tête
pour le suicide parce que on ya rien d
affaires que des frustrations la
frustration puis français c'était
dégressif le dire que ça mérite
qu'est ce que ça donne de vie
mais jamais menacé des joies aussi des
mechas quesada et un parent qui aime ton
fils ptc des affaires sur quoi francis
aura suivi une quinzaine d'heures de
réadaptation avec ses parents répartie
sur deux en un long parcours pour
reprendre contact avec le monde réel
c'est tellement complexe de l'idée que
un jeu plus devenir qu'est en fait
quelque chose pour remplacer dans une
vie c'est la plus grosse menace que ce
qu'on peut pour ce type de dépendance
le sevrage n'est pas la solution
préconisée puisqu'il était possible de
bannir tous les écrans de nos vies on va
être moins dans l'interdît plutôt d'en
créer un espace mais dans un cadre par
exemple est ce que toutes les choses
sont faites à la maison après sorbes
ayant un temps de jeu un temps de
plaisir c'est que le jeu prenne sa juste
place
la réadaptation vise aussi à amener le
jeune a diversifié ses jeux vidéo et à
varier ses activités
amérique
m
[Musique]
mathieu marche plus grands centres et
m'attend sur la musique et
justement montchamp j'ai lu ça me
trouver un bête la partie de la première
session cgem pour moi c'est vraiment la
meilleure chose que oui
et livre ce qui dit
les états sont le franc s'est améliorée
dans les céréales il pu mériter cette
confiance de l'installer liens et moi
d'aller dans la dernière année
la relation est beaucoup plus agréable
on est capables de se parler d'autre
chose de toujours jeux vidéo ou de mia
manière c'est vraiment le fun justement
de voir qu'aujourd'hui j'ai réussi à
sortir de ce trou le but de réaliser à
quel point ça fait pas bon ça
et au final ça devrait un jeu de baston
[Musique]